Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
What's one interview question you ask every prospective employee?
I did employ quite a lot of people in my life
in various positions.
And at the moment,
at this point in time
that I have my own business
and I'm looking for people to collaborate,
what I really try to sense
is what are their deepest motivations
because if their deepest motivations
align with my deepest motivations,
everything will work.
But no matter how inspiring,
you know, impressive they are,
all the toolbox in the world
cannot replace the right motivation,
and this is actually what I'm looking for.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.